MAN: Hey, Shelby!
Hey, Shelby!
What the hell's going on?
MAN: Hey, Shelby!
[inaudible]
Probably need a chain or
a rope, or something, huh?
MAN: Probably, and a saw, maybe.
SHELBY: I'm gonna go
back up there, man.
- OK.
- Not a thing.
SHELBY: Looks like you
got a big one to me!
[laughs] All right.
Thank you, man.
NARRATOR: Around these
parts, neighbor always
helps a neighbor out.
And the swamp man's
happy to oblige.
Hey, there it is.
- There it is.
- Wow.
SHELBY: Blocking, eh?
Yeah, it is.
Son of a bitch.
SHELBY: It's all the
way across, ain't it?
NARRATOR: Seems a
greedy local fisherman's
fenced off his honey
hole, trying to keep
the best spot to himself.
That ain't right, man.
People hungry
after these storms.
Can't keep it all to yourself.
WOMAN: What do
you want me to do?
SHELBY: I don't know.
We've got to get it
out of here, somehow.
NARRATOR: In the swamp, blocking
a fishing hole's 'bout as
crooked as a dog's hind legs.
That's blocking the
damn fishing hole, man,
for them people to fish in.
Don't look like there's anything
to tie it to on it, does it?
WOMAN: Don't look like it.
NARRATOR: And Shelby sure as
hell ain't gonna stand for it.
WOMAN: So what's a good way
to get this out of the way?
Hold on a minute.
Let me get it.
I don't know.
I hope you can pull
that thing up, man.
Might be the best thing to
do is to run through it.
I'm about to do some
community service.
Look out, junior.
Here we go!
WOMAN: Oh my god.
Shelby is [bleep] crazy.
Hold on now, we're
gonna go through it.
[bleep]
SHELBY: Get out the way!
[cheering]
- Damn!
Damn!
Oh my god, look!
SHELBY: Oh, man!
NARRATOR: Problem solved.
Oh, look at this [bleep], man.
NARRATOR: And it's been
a memorable first day
on the water for his new hand.
Every day with Shelby is like,
fly by the seat your pants.
You never know what's
going to happen.
Yeah, that would've
frickin' killed me!
Man!
[inaudible] Boy, you lucky.
[bleep]
WOMAN: Look at that.
SHELBY: Huh?
They can get in there now.
The older I get, the better
I get wreckin' [bleep]..
[laughs]